were your parents divorced no shockingly
wait and her parents um recently or they
still in South Africa oh yeah yeah yeah
should I show the video I keep showing
the same video on everyone's [__] I
don't need to see it no it's hilarious
this would be is right up what we were
right up it's actually perfect I don't
want to see it no my father did his his
second ever did his second ever
real on Instagram okay just show the
second picture well yeah there's no
internet here um I can't show it I have
absolutely no internet oh here it is
second ever real uh and he he blared I
got to get the sound on he blared um
what the account I can just okay pull up
Pete Pete that's yeah Pete to love yes
I'm getting my dad more views also I
shared it and he's got oh yeah he's got
way more one of his views is 28 this one
has 1,667 W let's get more views on this
thing let's get more views on this thing
blow my dad out Instagram so um non
divorce they're insane people they're
very insane I got in trouble when I was
at my parents' Cottage this summer for
using two
towels are you not can't use two towels
I I apparently the dock towel supposed
to be the dock towel and then I supposed
to use a separate towel for the shower I
don't want Lake ass and clean ass I got
I got in trouble they're very crazy mean
trouble they yell at you oh my dad call
me a [__] idiot yeah my dad's psycho
he's um Eastern European very Bulgarian
man very anger no accent born in Canada
but um his his parents were arranged
marriage they were so what are the towel
rules the the rule there's so many rules
parents get get set in their like in
their [__] and they're just very my
parents are very anal so everything's
like squeaky clean if I go to put a cup
down there's a [__] like coaster that
is exactly how my parents are it drives
okay yeah so it's the elephant one here
we go here we go yeah so pay close
attention to the second reel here second
second pick right there there it is okay
go back you got to go back to that go
back to that oh it's a poo that's really
thick it's so thick it's psychotic yeah
but he T his timing is impeccable I mean
I think he music ridiculous music is
insane Times Like These by fighters huge
so they were were they strict growing up
oh yes very it's such a huge [__] it's
crazy isn't it that kind a different
kind of like mental torture to grow up
with someone that anal cuz my mom has
like OCD and Symmetry and cleanliness
and hygiene and deep cleaning and no two
towels the exact same like I think the
the cleaning Parts I'm glad I got that
stuff but like they were I had a very
weird childhood I used to Highland dance
Scottish Highland dancing K bag pipes
yeah my whole life from 3: to 18 so my
mom was a teacher so I I not only had
like this like insane Eastern European
dad but I had my mother was my dancing
teacher and I was not good but she was
like you're going to be good and I was
like I'm I'm like built like my dad I'm
like I'm not going to be a [__] good
dancer so I like there was like one year
I was good when I was nine and I have to
come home on my lunch break and practice
like I had no [__] friends in school
it was a nightmare I was like very very
bizarre we all we did was travel I watch
no movies as a kid growing out cuz i' be
like on the road every [__] weekend
dancing do you know what Highland is the
kills in the bag pipe
yeah yeah yeah it was very I saw
braveart you saw braveart a braveart
joke yes um what does that do to you
though like when you were like forced to
did you enjoy it eventually or is it
something no no I really didn't I didn't
I knew it wasn't good and I was
competitive so I was like better at
Sports and [__] but then I my mom was
like my mom had a dancer who was super
[__] good and she's like and everyone
like knew her because of that dancer so
I think she's like my girls have to be
good me and my sister were like we're
horrendous the second we hit High School
we're like drinking and smoking
excessively so it's like we're not good
so you have a sister have a sister
younger younger yes yeah she wild she
was she's pregnant now wildly pregnant
okay good good and you guys are best
friends yes we are but you guys grew up
in that strict environment yes we're
both really and then how did comedy come
about I think they it just kind of came
out of me always performing in front of
people and like because I'm like on
stage dancing and I would always yeah
but it's odd to me because when I see
you perform it's like I want to say this
in the nicest way
possible then this means it ain't going
to sound good if you open with that yeah
yeah it's and and and people have told
me it's like that's
you like that's what people see see me
see me and you yeah in terms of energy
energy maybe but like physicality no
materal I'm talking about no in terms of
energy okay yeah cuz we're both well I
mean we're both high energy and manic
you know what I mean yeah we're both
very high energy manic yeah like pacing
we don't stop once I go into the club I
know you're performing did I hear you
from down the
hallway
I do okay yeah yeah yeah so so when I
look at you I go wow like where did that
come from like because
you're you know mean and combative I
think that is like dancing like if you
see Highland dancing it's very rigid
it's very forceful it's very like it's a
very aggressive form of dance you dance
over [__] swords for God's sakes like
it's very bizarre I don't know where the
[__] came from I came out of my shell in
grade eight and then I was like a
psychopath and then you were rebellious
in high school I got arrested in high
school wow
you who' you jump no me and my friend
fought somebody but it was more yeah I
started this fight with this girl and
then what you call
her I said that she had lice um are you
being real are you being real you have
lice yeah you [__] yeah yeah yeah I
love lice you love lice I love lice have
you had lice oh yeah so much sweetie she
said lice not
rice just a joke just a joke you love
that joke like that's the biggest laugh
the whole this is going to sound so
[__] sad but I felt like I was devoid
of a lot of like loving touch when I was
a kid but I got it when I had Lies when
I had lies my aunties and my mom would
sift through my hair doing this a lot so
I felt super like